parents are especially mortified by what
happened
so hard to sometimes leave your children
in the care of someone else
but it's an unavoidable part of
parenthood so we wanted to know
what are some things that parents can
either look for or do
to have some peace of mind 8 news now
reporter orc omana joining us with some
of those answers tonight worco
well denise and brian parents just want
to feel comfortable knowing that their
children
are safe with their babysitters and
while gut feelings
are often a good indicator that things
are okay there are extra steps you can
take
and even certifications to look out for
you want them to be safe and secure
parents say protecting their kids is
their top priority so leaving them in
the care of someone else can be tricky
sonia pedowick is a mother of three and
says testing potential babysitters can
help put your mind at ease
do a trial run have them come and spend
time in your home
with you there see what some of their
social skills are
in interacting with your child other
parents often rely on word of mouth from
friends and neighbors
being able to know and trust somebody
based off of their experience
with other families in the valley
definitely just kind of helps to
reassure me
according to pregnancy birth and
baby.org you should also ask babysitters
tough questions those include do they
know first aid how will they deal with
emergencies
and how will they discipline your child
the american red cross
also offers babysitting courses
recommended for those age 11
and up we cover topics such as basic
care for
infants and children basic first aid
child behavior those who complete the
course get a certificate like this the
red cross says that should give parents
more confidence in the caregiver
someone has taken the time and the
initiative and that's something pedowick
will look out for too
i think it shows some maturity on their
part if they've gone
and gone that extra mile
now to sign up for the red cross
babysitting courses just go to their
website redcross.org
go up to training and certification and
then you'll search
for the babysitting and childcare just
click on that option and then you can
search
based on your location let's say that
we're in henderson here
you can search there and then see
available courses we'll have a link to
this website and other resources
on our website that's eightnewsnow.com
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
workout mana 8 news now